Traductor: Antoni Barceló Riera
Revisor: Jenny Lam-Chowdhury
Crispy y Chewy, dos hombrecitos
de jengibre racionales,
están paseando cuando,
de repente, un zorro los atrapa.
Los ve tan felices que,
en vez de comérselos,
decide que pondrá a prueba
su amistad con un dilema cruel:
preguntará a cada uno
si salvaría o sacrificaría al otro.
Pueden hablarlo, pero no
saber qué ha elegido el otro
hasta que cada uno por su cuenta
haya tomado una decisión.
Si ambos deciden salvar al otro,
solo se comerá un miembro de cada uno,
pero si uno decide salvar a su amigo
y el otro, sacrificarlo,
se comerá al que se haya salvado
y el otro podrá huir intacto.
En cambio, si ambos eligen el sacrificio,
se comerá tres miembros de cada uno.
En la teoría de juegos, a este escenario
se le llama el Dilema del Prisionero.
Para imaginarnos cómo actuarán
estos hombrecitos de jengibre racionales
podemos hacer un esquema
con los resultados de cada elección.
Las filas representan
las elecciones de Crispy,
mientras que las columnas
figuran las de Chewy.
Por otra parte,
los números de las casillas
ilustran los resultados
de cada decisión,
que se cuantifican en función
de los miembros que conservarían.
La pregunta es:
¿triunfará la amistad en el juego?
En primer lugar, consideremos
las opciones de Chewy.
Si Crispy lo salva, Chewy escapará ileso
porque Crispy se sacrificará,
pero si su amigo lo sacrifica,
Chewy conservará un miembro
si también decide sacrificar a Crispy.
Sea cual sea la decisión de Crispy,
el mejor resultado para Chewy
implica sacrificar a su amigo.
Y las mismas opciones van para Crispy.
Esta es la conclusión estándar
del Dilema del Prisionero:
los individuos se traicionarán mutuamente.
La estrategia de sacrificar al compañero
es lo que los teóricos del juego llaman
el Equilibrio de Nasch, es decir,
los individuos no obtendrán beneficios
si se desvían de esta estretegia.
Crispy y Chewy
tomarán la misma decisión,
y el zorro, por su parte,
se atiborrará de pan de jengibre
y los dejará con tan solo una pierna.
La historia normalmente terminaría aquí,
pero resulta que un mago
había presenciado los hechos
y les dice a Crispy y a Chewy que,
como castigo por su traición,
estarían condenados a repetir
el dilema de por vida
y que cada día despertarían
otra vez con todos los miembros.
¿Cuál es, ahora, la cuestión?
Es el Dilema del Prisionero Iterado,
que cambia las reglas del juego
porque los hombrecitos de jengibre
recurrirán a las decisiones futuras
para negociar las del presente.
La estrategia sería la siguiente:
cada día ambos decidirían salvar al otro.
Si alguna vez alguno
eligiese el sacrificio,
el otro se vengaría eligiendo
sacrificarlo toda la eternidad.
¿Sería esto suficiente para que
estos pastelitos animados
al fin se decidiesen a colaborar?
Para resolverlo,
hay que hacer otra apreciación:
a los hombrecitos de jengibre
probablemente les importa más
el futuro que el presente.
Dicho de otro modo,
dividirán el valor que les dan
a sus miembros del futuro
por un número que llamaremos delta.
Es como la inflación
que erosiona el valor del dinero.
Si delta es 1/2 , valorarán
los miembros del día 2
la mitad de lo que valoran
los del día 1;
los del día 3, un cuarto
de lo que valoran los del día 1, etc.
Si delta es 0, significa que no valoran
nada en absoluto sus miembros futuros,
con lo cual reiterarán su decisión inicial
del sacrificio mutuo infinitamente.
En cambio, si delta se aproxima a 1,
harán todo lo posible
por evitar el sufrimiento infinito
de perder los 3 miembros,
con lo cual elegirán
salvarse el uno al otro.
El cambio de opinión
se producirá en un punto intermedio.
Podemos hallarlo
escribiendo las series infinitas
que representan cada estrategia,
configurándolas de igual manera
y dividiéndolas por delta.
El resultado es 1/3, es decir,
que, como Crispy y Chewy
se preocupan por el futuro al menos 1/3
de lo que se preocupan por el presente,
es mejor que se salven
y cooperen para siempre.
Este análisis no solo es aplicable
a galletas y hechiceros,
sino también a situaciones reales
como los intercambios comerciales
y la política internacional.
Los líderes deben asumir
que las decisiones que tomen hoy
condicionarán las que tomen
sus adversarios mañana.
El egoísmo puede imponerse
en el corto plazo,
pero con los incentivos adecuados,
la cooperación pacífica
no solo es posible,
sino también matemáticamente ideal.
Tal vez la eternidad de los hombrecitos
de jengibre estará hecha migas,
pero mientras conserven una pierna,
tendrán una amistad bien horneada.